[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YES!
HAPPY MONDAY, MY ADORING AND
ADORABLE FANS.
I WOULD KISS EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU IF I WAS NOT SO
CONTAGIOUS.
BUT THANK YOU FOR THAT MAKING IS
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL TV SHOW IN
HISTORY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I KNOW.
IN HISTORY.
I WOULD NOT BELIEVE IT MYSELF
EXCEPT THAT THERE IT IS.
IN THE CHART I MADE AN HOUR AGO.
SUPER BOWL XLIX, FINAL MATCH
EPISODE GOOD THE LAST EPISODE OF
CHEERS.
AND THERE'S "GUTFELD!" IN THAT
MIDDLE, DOUBLING ALL OF THAT.
4 BILLION VIEWERS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THE DATA IS RIGHT THERE.
WE DID IT WITHOUT OUR STAFF
BREAKING INTO THE CAPITOL.
[LAUGHTER]
I BET YOU DID NOT KNOW THAT
STUFF.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN TWO DIFFERENT
WORLDS.
IN ONE WORLD.
YOU ARE THE HERO AND IN THE
OTHER, ARE THE BILLING.
I COULD BE THOR OR SAY 10.
EACH WORLDS MIRROR EACH OTHER.
FOR EXAMPLE IT WENT BROKE THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE HE WROTE
WOULD BE SO MR. TAMAYO -- SO YES
TO MAYOR.
IN THE OPPOSITE WOULD BE THE
REVERSE.
WE ARE TOLD BY THAT MAY GET THAT
YOU CAN'T RESPECT BOTH SIDES.
IT IS ONE OR THE OTHER.
THERE ARE 64 GENDERS BUT ONLY
ONE WORLDVIEW.
ONCE IN A WHILE IT IS GOOD WHEN
SOMEONE COMES ALONG TO REMIND US
THAT IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE THIS
WAY.
TAKE IT AWAY, SOTO.
>> Justice Sotomayor: I PROBABLY
DISAGREE WITH HIM MORE THAN ANY
OTHER JUSTICE.
WE HAVE NOT ENJOYED EACH OTHER'S
OPINIONS MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE
AND YET JUSTICE THOMAS IS THE
ONE JUSTICE IN THE BUILDING THAT
LITERALLY KNOWS EVERY EMPLOYEE'S
NAME.
HE IS A MAN WHO KEEPS -- CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT THE INSTITUTION,
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE
AND PEOPLE.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT VISION AND I
DO BUT I THINK WE SHARED A
COMMON UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
PEOPLE AND KINDNESS TOWARDS
THEM.
THAT IS WHY I CAN BE FRIENDS
WITH HIM AND STILL CONTINUE OUR
DAILY BATTLE.
>> Greg: THAT IS AWESOME AND IT
IS AWESOME FOR A REASON THAT I
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT SINCE I
HOSTED THAT POLITICAL TALK SHOW
ON ANIMAL PLANET BACK IN THE
'80s.
SCREW YOU PANDA.
I WOULD AT.
[LAUGHTER]
I HOSTED IT WITH CRONKITE BACK
IN THE DAY.
IN THIS WOKE RIDDLED IRAQ ANY
PRESENT SEEN COMMISERATING WITH